when it comes to what things look like
the western world is obsessed by
perfection by symmetry and ideal
proportion
this is a taste for beauty shaped by a
reverence for universal laws
mathematics and an appetite for the
perfect and the eternal
japanese aesthetics are however very
different indeed
and the core of the difference is
captured in a term for which western
languages have no direct equivalent
a term known as wabi-sabi
wabi-sabi refers to the beauty of the
impermanent
the imperfect the rustic and the
melancholy
it derives not from a love of
invincibility youth and flawlessness
but from a respect for what is passing
fragile
slightly broken and modest wabi-sabi
believes that things are always more
beautiful
for bearing the marks of age and
individuality
a trickle of glaze or a beautifully
repaired crack on a piece of pottery
are to be appreciated rather than made
invisible
wabi-sabi's history is intimately linked
with buddhism
and its suggestion that wisdom comes
from making peace
with our transitory imperfect and
unheroic natures
kyushu japan 1191 a monk known as ase
returns to japan from china with plans
to create japan's first
zen buddhist temple zen presents a
challenge to japan's indigenous
religions
shinto zen offers a complex
philosophical system
which presents nature with its constant
cycles of life and imperfect patterns
as a focus of meditation and a lens
through which to understand our own
transience
and emptiness zen will go on to be the
philosophical bedrock
of wabi-sabi 14th century japan
the meaning of two words wabi and sabi
begin to evolve and become more positive
than they had been
wabi had originally meant the misery and
loneliness of living in nature
away from human consolation but its
meaning now shifts
to refer to an almost exquisite
bittersweet melancholy at being on one's
own
sabby meanwhile which had originally
meant chill
lean or withered starts to denote the
marks of aging and
wear which can enhance an object it
refers to a positive
impermanence and the welcome and noble
signs of time
the ancient pattern of a pot or a crack
beautifully mended
are now called sabi
kyoto 1488 maratha shuko sits down to
write a letter to his student
furuji choin this document will come to
be known as the letter of the heart
and will define the ideal way that one
should drink tea
the tea ceremony and lays out the
aesthetic
of wabi-sabi the tea ceremony had
originated as a way for monks to stay
awake
in order to practice long periods of zen
meditation
but recently it's been overtaken by the
ruling class of warlords or
shoguns they use it as a way of showing
off expensive vessels and utensils
imported from china
the tea ceremony has become flashy often
in elaborate and gaudy surroundings
and has slipped a long way from its
spiritual roots
now shuka redesigns the tea ceremony
with the ideals of wabi-sabi
in mind the fashion at the time is to
enjoy tea or on a balcony while looking
at the full moon
but shuker claims that he has no taste
for the full moon
instead he urges his student to
appreciate the more subtle interplay of
shadows
on the half of the moon or the partially
clouded moon
he also stresses that one should abandon
the perfect and lustrous tea drinking
cups of the chinese
which seem to evoke the flawlessness of
the full moon and
instead to commission more rustic wear
from japanese artisans who will make
little errors in the glaze
and let these be a deliberate part of
their work
kyoto 1582 senor rikyu is summoned to
the service of toyotomi hideyoshi
a powerful warlord who unites the
warring factions of feudal japan
he commissions riku to create a tea
ceremony that can help to foster peace
along with shuko senor rikyu is revered
in japan as the father of the modern tea
ceremony
and the most perfect practitioner of
wabi-sabi
a story that is most often used to
illustrate the spirit of wabi-sabi
is taken from his life one day riku
asked the disciple to clean his tea
house
and the young boy worked all day to
scrub and sweep every inch of the house
and garden
when riku came to inspect it he reached
up and shook a maple tree
overhanging the path the sprinkling of
leaves that fell
brought wabi-sabi to the scene thus the
man-made and the natural
artifice and random chants were united
in a perfect expression of beauty and
wisdom
riku goes further than shuko in
undermining the high tastes of the
shoguns
and strips everything non-essential from
his tea ceremony
the pots he uses are often directly
taken from peasant environments
or are modeled after a particularly
rustic roof tile that he spots while
walking through a local village
riku also codifies the movements of the
tea ceremony
creating the perfectly economical and
graceful motions for preparing tea
with a minimum of fuss thereby adding
wabi-sabi to the very core of the ritual
unfortunately for riku his boss the
warlord hirayoshi
comes from a peasant background and
begins to fear that the whole process
is maybe an elaborate joke at his
expense
this causes him to order riku to commit
harakiri in an eerie parallel to
socrates's demise
riku holds a final tea ceremony among
his closest friends
before obediently stabbing himself
through the stomach
today all the great schools of tea trace
their lineage back to riku
and all follow the motions and
traditions that he set out the maker of
the humble tile that he so admired
was known as raku and rakupots are still
made today
and appreciated as the greatest
embodiment of wabi-sabi
if you take tea in the silver pavilion
in kyoto the birthplace of the formal
tea ceremony in japan
you can drink from the same cup as the
troublesome hitter yoshi once sipped
from
ido 1684 matsuo basho the father of the
haiku
and japan's most revered poet sets off
on the first of his great pilgrimages
these aimless wanderings will take him
to the heart of solitude and nature
and help him to capture the spirit of
wabisabian words
a depressive with a great talent basho
takes joy in wandering the dangerous
roads around edo disguised as a beggar
here he distills the fragile beauty of
the sights around him
into poetry that tries to spot the
eternal through the fleeting moment
we can hear the beautiful desolation in
one of his most famous haikus
solitary now standing amidst the
blossoms
is a cypress tree ginza district tokyo
2013
an enormous new outlet of louis vuitton
opens built by the japanese architect
yoon aoki 45 percent of all japanese
women
are now estimated to own a bag by the
french luxury goods firm
featuring western ideals of shininess
perfection and symmetry
whereby sabi is like many traditional
japanese ideas
under enormous threat from the
consumerist values of the west
wabi-sabi is at one level an idea that
relates to pottery
drinking tea in the history of japan but
at another it's a lesson for all of us
for all times because the place we
really have to come to terms with
imperfection
melancholy and age is in ourselves
wabi-sabi is a giant marketing effort
which urges us to take a second look
at what we might otherwise dismiss or
treat with disdain
it recognizes that our tastes are not
fixed and that if someone with talent
and artistic grace
urges us to look more sympathetically at
some moss
a slightly wonky teacup or indeed the
wise wrinkled face of a friend or
relative
we will be able to find charm and beauty
here too
our notions of beauty and interest are
relative and open to
change and improvement with the ideals
of wabi-sabi in mind
we may learn to find greater
satisfaction in the humble moments
in a walk down a slightly crooked path
on an overcast autumn day
or in a less than blemish-free house
face
or soul
if you like our films take a look at our
shop theschooloflife.com forward slash
shop you'll find lots of thoughtful
books games
stationery and more
let's say you just had a big row with
someone close to you
they behaved terribly maybe broke
something and said something hideous to
you
it's so tempting to give up on them and
just
hate them but there's an